[Musique]
pour amplifier le petit bulletin ici
avec votre nom votre prénom vous dernier
le sens autre adresse voilà couple 1860
quatrième inscriptions pour la
médiathèque du sundgau
un chiffre qui prend des allures de
records quand on sait que l'antenne
altkirchoise de la médiathèque
départementale a ouvert ses portes il ya
tout juste trois mois dans les allées au
fil des rayonnages des milliers
d'ouvragés pour petits et grands des dvd
des cd et même des jeux vidéo du
bibliophile amateurs de grands
classiques aux cosplayeurs fanas de
mangue à chacun petit trouver son
bonheur la nouvelle médiathèque attire
un public aussi bigarrée que divers et
pour les élus départementaux qui ont
soutenu ce projet c'est sa principale
raison d'être c'est un lieu de rencontre
moi je je je vois simple comme
finalement une fonction que
remplissaient à l'époque nos cafés dans
les villages où les personnes se
retrouve quelles que soient leurs
l'heure on va dire leur niveau social ou
leur niveau culturel ou voilà des gens
se croisent se rencontrent se parlent
une médiathèque s'est pas seulement un
endroit où l'on vient emprunter un livre
c'est aussi et surtout j'allais dire un
endroit de rencontre un endroit où on se
rencontre entre générations
un endroit également où on peut échanger
quelle que soit sa catégorie sociale
quelle que soit sa catégorie
socioprofessionnelle et donc c'est très
important qu'il y ait ce lieu où l'on
peut échanger refaire le monde se
cultiver et le fait qu'il y ait en moins
de trois mois d'ouverture de cette
médiathèque départementale d'altkirch
quelques 1800 abonnés montrent qu'il y
avait une forte attente de la population
du sud asie
nouveau lieu nouvelle équipe
de l'autre côté du comptoir c'est aussi
d'éclectisme qui règne le personnel est
constitué bien sûr de bibliothécaires
professionnels mais aussi d'agents venus
de différents services départementaux
motivé par le challenge que représentait
ce projet si l'ouverture ne s'est pas
fait sans quelques bugs
les agents sont fiers du travail
accompli on ne peut qu'être ravi de ses
trois premiers mois cette médiathèque à
l'origine était calibré sur une un
bassin de vie de dix mille habitants et
en moins de trois mois nous avons
attendre atteint les 1864 usagers ce qui
représente 20 18% de la population ce
qui est mis plus qu'encourageant on a un
retour très positif de cette médiathèque
les habitants sont aussi très content
des collections qu'on leur propose
ils nous réclament d'ores et déjà des
animations que nous allons mettre en
oeuvre commencé à mettre en oeuvre dans
les jours ou les semaines qui viennent
petite soeur de la médiathèque
départementale de colmar depuis juin
l'antenne d'altkirch a pris le relais
pour le sud du département
sa mission première assurer à tous sur
l'ensemble du territoire un meilleur
accès aux livres et plus généralement à
la culture pour le département principal
financeur de la structure elle était
indispensable pour faire face à
l'éloignement de cette partie du
territoire
alors on fait en 2003 les élus avaient
identifié quand même un grand besoin de
lieux de lecture publique dans le
territoire on avait c'est vrai une
déficience de ce côté là mais le
diagnostic avait été fait à l'époque par
le département que le sundgau était mal
desservies donc il avait été décidé
assez rapidement de créer une
médiathèque départementale bis dans le
sud du département est donc en 2003
l'idée a germé pour finalement se
concrétiser on va dire par le biais
d'une convention 2015
nous sommes à la bibliothèque municipale
de wittersdorf à quelques kilomètres
d'altkirch
madame et qu elle vient rencontrer sa
collègue une visite qui n'est pas que de
pure courtoisie la petite structure
municipale fait partie du réseau de la
médiathèque du sundgau
il parle prêt d'ouvragés partenariat
événementiel et formation c'est une des
missions effectivement du conseil
départemental qui doit venir en soutien
à l'action des autres collectivités
notamment des communes la bibliothèque
où la médiathèque départementale du
sundgau irrigue déjà depuis son
ouverture
quelques dix huit bibliothèques
publiques donc dans le sundgau
nous sommes ouverts au public c'est
j'irai la face visible de l'iceberg
parallèlement nous avons des missions
départementales
à ce titre nous venons en soutien des
bibliothèques de notre réseau par le
prêt par exemple de collection de
documents les prêts de supports
d'animation des expositions des
kamishibaï des liseuses ce genre de
choses et nous complotant complétant par
notre offre par une programmation
d'animation et de formation
j'espère aussi que le fait d'avoir un
partenariat facilitée par le biais de
cette médiathèque va peut-être favoriser
la création de petites bibliothèques
dans les territoires plus nombreuses 9
heures du matin alors que les portes de
la médiathèque sont encore claude marie
anna et saïd s'apprête à partir avec
bibliobus 10 arrêts au programme de la
journée dans les petites communes à
proximité de la frontière suisse
pionnier dans le développement des
bibliobus le département du haut rhin
est un des derniers
maintenir ce service indispensable pour
les communes rurales sans bibliothèque
alors un bibliobus au plus tôt un média
but c'est en quelque sorte une
médiathèque qui tenais rente qui va à la
rencontre des haut rhinois en sillonnant
les routes départementales et qui va
dans les villages les plus éloignés des
bibliothèques pour permettre aux gens
d'avoir accès à la lecture et une fois
par mois ça va trois quarts d'heure
parfois une journée les habitants de ce
village et environs sont invités à se
rendre au bibliobus et ses lieux lieu de
rendez vous de tous les amateurs de
lecture de musique de vidéo voilà donc
c'est un sont des temps très conviviaux
très familiaux c'est très sympathique
dernier volet de l'action de la
médiathèque du chai ngo a mené la
lecture aux personnes qui en sont le
plus éloignés handicapés personnes âgées
ou encore familles en grande difficulté
sociale
une action qui va de pair avec les
politiques de solidarité du département
pour marilena ancienne assistante
sociale agir sur l'accès à la culture
c'est agir sur le social la lecture les
cris la culture de façon plus générale
c'est vraiment un formidable outil
d'insertion c'est un vecteur très
puissant pour lutter contre les
inégalités sociales
ça permet de favoriser l'estimé de soi
de dépasser ses limites de mettre en
exergue ses compétences étalons
d'échanger avec les autres d'aiguiser
son esprit critique
donc c'est effectivement des outils qui
peuvent aider qui peuvent permettre au
front de dépasser leurs limites de pipe
les actions sont mises en place à
destination d'un autre public
les réfugiés du centre d'accueil de
ferrette objectif favoriser la
découverte du français autant qu offrir
un moment de répit dans ces vies brisées
une expérience forte qui pour nombre de
réfugiés fut la première confrontation
avec une société où l'on peut accéder à
la culture sans tabou ni censure